so in 1996 nikon came out with arguably
the most robust most durable the most
advanced slr camera on the market the
nikon f5
and
this
has held up even to 2021. now today as
of october 28th
they're back
a little bit of the dna of the f5
but of course with all the latest tech
is the nikon
z9
now we're gonna be taking this out
through the uh drung bird park here in
singapore also we're gonna go to the dog
park and uh test out some footage with
my dog praja running around this is a
first impressions of the camera this is
a pre-production sample the firmware is
not final you could say the uh the
physical attributes of the camera are
but inside things could be tweaked with
that let's go inside the bird park let's
get out of the rain and let's see how
the z9 handles birds wet weather and
dogs let's check it out all right so
we're gonna
catch these flamingos here now one of
the things about the z9 of course it
does animal tracking when you set the
animal tracking that also includes birds
so
i think we need the 500
we're gonna need the 500. all right so
the 7200 was a little bit short so now
we're moving over to the 500 f 5.6 with
the new ftz adapter on it as you can
tell there's no tripod mount on it it's
much more compact so this 500 should get
some really nice shots with the flamingo
yes
got it all right
pinpoint let's do it
next location
whoa bye birdie fly
fly
this is hard
burning is not easy
so let's talk about some of the standout
features on the z9 first off you can do
it to 20 frames per second shooting in
raw 30 frames per second shooting at
normal jpeg and 120 frames per second
out of 11 megapixel jpeg images now 120
frames per second is basically just
taking a still image out of a video for
that matter will this be something
people use it depends on the
the scenario sports wildlife you need
that precise moment an 11 megapixel
image is plenty big enough for
publication or for even social media or
web for that matter
one of the great things about the z9 is
there's no mechanical shutter in this
camera it is all electronic shutter
so this is the first we've seen outside
the sigma pivot the sigma fp was a
different camera you had a rolling
shutter you had banding you had all
those issues that really would deter
someone from an electronic shutter
but with the z9 you have none of that as
you can tell from some of the images
we're showing you here and you'll see
throughout this review
there's no distortion no banding no
warping
everything is just precise and crisp
so this is something one of the great
attributes of the z9 that i think we're
going to be seeing in cameras going
forward also for you sd card folks out
there
put them away
cfxpress type b only
or xqd for that matter but yes this
camera is designed for high speed
photography and for video and an sd card
is not going to cut it in the z9 so
it's time to upgrade but there are a lot
of other options out there so yes the
cards can be expensive it is an
investment but you're going to get that
speed of performance you need to
maximize potential of the z9 now in
terms of video you can obviously do 10
up to 8k
30p on this and you can do analog hlg
pro res 422 will be coming very soon on
this 4k 120. so and you also have a lot
of raw video coming in a new update in
the future as well so you have a lot of
great attributes to the z9 when it comes
to video so were people that were
complaining about nikon and saying hey
look nikon's not really known for video
at all
that's changed here with the z9 this is
a true
hybrid camera system through and through
the auto focusing algorithm has been
improved you have two xb7 processors
inside of this thing now so you're
getting the fastest camera that nikon
has ever made to date
this is the z9
and we are damn excited to try it out so
as you can tell i'm wet we're battling
the rain weather resistant
let's shoot some images
now we're in a covered area here at the
bird park
there's some birds flying around
i moved on to the 70 to 200 here so
let's uh
see how this works
eye tracking is fantastic
wow very nice
nice
i mean obviously this is pre-production
it does lock on pretty good at times
it still hunts a little bit but this is
a lot better than i shot with the z72
and the z62 for that matter so again
pre-production
when it locks on it does get the eye of
the bird
and it's just solid it's very like
you have confidence that when you know
this is in focus you're getting the shot
wait for these birds to fly if i can
capture them
see what's going to get a bird flying on
it's on the top lower lower yourself
lower down lower down
okay so in terms of auto focusing
and what i'm noticing here again
as i mentioned pre-production but
it does seem to hunt a little bit with
birds obviously these are moving quite
fast now when they're static like this
it's not an issue at all
but when they're in flight it's having a
hard time sometimes detecting them
so
this
again could be pre-production could just
be because of whatever the case may be
but it is something i'm noticing it's
finding some challenges here with this
portion of it uh but again but when you
nail focus the image is beautiful it's
razor sharp
that's me
i'm trying to get the bird to move
right
i know you feel me right
it's really wet today isn't it
yeah i know what you mean it's really a
wet situation and your friend right
there doesn't want to fly for me so it's
making my job a little bit more
difficult to review this
exactly at work
okay you're good so one of the things i
realized of course is the settings
inside the af system
the z9 it is quite advanced so
we reset the camera we
had to avoid obstacles and things inside
the wind it actually does lock on a lot
faster than before so
um again there's a lot of uh
nuances of this camera that i think will
be quite new for some of the people that
are used to using more of the consumer
grade uh nikon mirrorless z cameras so
you know we're learning as we go along
until we have the nikon reps here with
us to help us out throughout this so i
am noticing the hit rate is a bit better
now um it is locking up focus a lot
faster
i'm using the 500 5.6 i'm going through
the uh
the gate on this a bit
you see a little bit of that mesh but
he's pretty sharp
i gotta say these buggies are very
comfortable the drunk bird car but you
know where to make them even better
secret lab chairs inside as a matter of
fact this video is brought to you by
secret lab check out the software 2.0 as
well as the pew leather 2.0 for the
titan evo 2022 chairs there's a variety
of different themes you got batman
superman harley quinn joker and so many
more they have the magnetic foam pillow
on the back of them as well as the
magnetic pads gel pads for the titan evo
and better lumbar support and secret lab
also even makes desks for more
information check out secretlab.co
so come over this way someone said they
fly around
as you can tell i've been here a few
times yaki
from using
an f mount lens
like the 505.6 versus let's say the 7200
z mount 2.8
the focusing is the same it's very fast
it's extremely fast
say that the the z9 i mean the image
quality coming out of it is beautiful
even at higher iso when you crank up the
shutter speed the images is clean and
i'm not of course i'm looking at jpegs
on the camera right now but um i'm
really impressed now in terms of the
settings inside of this you have a 3.69
million dot evf it's a widescreen evf so
actually in a way it's very different
from what we're seeing on other cameras
it almost looks like you're looking at a
a television set in a lot of ways which
is nice because you really see a wider
area of
viewing and the display in the back this
is a 3.2 inch display i think it's like
about 2 million dots thereabouts we'll
put the exact specs right here below on
the screen uh here but it's very uh
clear very sharp but the thing about the
evf is don't think 3.69 million dots is
a low res because it's the optics inside
of it that make it really good as a
matter of fact this rivals some of the
5.76 and even some of the 9 million dot
ebfs i've tried on other cameras out
there this is a very good evf so much so
this might be one of the top ebs i've
used on a mirrorless camera even at
lower resolution
surprising i know but
you know that's what happens when you
have good glass good optics
you get very good performance out of
this
um in terms of ergonomics it feels
really good in the hands i mean there's
no issues at all with that uh the weight
yes this is a beefier camera and uh for
some that want a smaller camera you
might offer the z62 or the z72 but of
course you're not gonna get the same
performance as you're gonna get there's
a pelican right there flying and we just
missed him
we just missed him damn it
okay
you see a pelican fly just let me know i
mean but it doesn't really bother me and
i think with especially with the video
attributes of this camera the speed and
everything involved in it
this size is needed you need the battery
power you need that heat dissipation
inside of it to actually
help cool the camera off while you're
you know pushing it to its extremes so
what i'll do right now is uh while we're
waiting for one of these pelicans to fly
off is we'll try some 8k video right
here see what it looks like with the 500
5.6
now you're not your typical video lens
but
in wildlife if you want to get close up
let's give it a shot let's see how it
goes
also one of the nice things that nikon
has done with this they actually put the
record button right here and it's not
usually here like some cameras but it's
right here and it's actually raised so
you'll know you're going to know just by
touch where the record button is at so
let's go in here
now recording at 8k
high tracking is in play
because we've got two hours and four
minutes
it's a
h.265 8-bit
absolutely beautiful
so now we're testing ak at 25 p so
you're actually getting a sense of what
it's like now and as you can tell it is
a very clear image
looks fantastic and zach once you walk
with me a little bit let's see how the
image stabilization is on the z9 so
we're actually on uneven ground here on
this ramp area so
you're going to get a sense of how the
stabilization is if you want to do a
walk and talk kind of a thing
but overall i've been really impressed
with the z9 so far i have to say that
nikon has really knocked out of the park
with this i've been very impressed now
while the auto focusing when tracking
birds is going to take as i mentioned
some adjusting and some experience
you know i've found that you know
shooting images of zacky or even bird
still the dynamic range out of these
images is fantastic the sharpness
uh the focusing is so much faster than
the z7 2 and z62 that this is a big big
change compared to the other two then
let's say for the canon r5 or the r3 and
the uh sony alpha one i would say that
nikon is right there with them now i
think this is a very good competition
between these three
for some really good auto focusing out
there so there's no more i'm gonna be
like well am i missing something going
with one system or the other i think
they're all three really comparable it
just depends what kind of glass you want
and the colors that you like and of
course just everything else that comes
along with it but i have to say the z9
has really really impressed me just saw
a pelican fly off and i missed that shot
because i was waiting for so long but
now we're just doing video right here
for this case but it is what it is
now as i mentioned earlier there will be
pro res available on this camera soon
after launch but right now you have hlg
and end log and we're actually shooting
end log right now h265 10 bit internal
at 8k
25p
this is pretty damn impressive
great mirrorless camera system
this is impressive so we're going to
grade it you're going to see the before
and after what it looks like on grade
but uh
i got to tell you man this camera is
very impressive and there goes a pelican
right there what i needed to shoot the
entire time
i missed it
but i'm showing you end log in 8k so
there you go
okay so now we're going to test some low
light performance with this uh new
sensor here we're actually going to take
some photos of the penguins
and
it's pretty dark where we're at i mean
obviously there's some light in their
area here
there's 10 000.
we're going to go down to the lowest
setting here to see how sharp this can
be
so we just finished our round here at
the drunk bird park big thanks to the
entire staff and team for allowing us to
test drive the z9 here and for uh
shuttling us around here in the buggy
now we're going to go to the dog park
with my roddy praha we're going to see
how she is
with the z9 with a tracker some dogs
playing around and maybe catching the
balls and all that kind of fun stuff but
in terms of battery life in case you're
wondering on this we've shot thousands
of photos here already at the bird park
we came in with a full battery and i
have still
over half a battery left on this camera
system so i don't know exactly what the
separate rating is on the z9 but i think
they're very conservative on the numbers
because this
is a powerful beast and the battery life
is just
i mean it's just sipping juice this is
really impressive anyway uh let me get
cleaned up dried off a little bit and
we'll see you at the dog park
okay we're now here at the dog park and
we're gonna test animal tracking 3d
tracking and animal tracking with my dog
praja now here's the thing my dog's a
rottweiler so predominantly she has
black fur which is very hard for some
cameras to track a lot of the times
especially with the shadows of trees and
foliage around there so we're going to
see how well this camera performs in
that regard also there's some other dogs
around here and they'll be throwing
we'll be throwing around the ball
they'll be chasing each other so we're
going to see how well this camera
performs in situations like this with
the 70 to 200 on it of course the f 2.8
one the
best 7200s i've ever used to date
let's see how this performs
[Music]
so
[Music]
got it yep whoa
with the spit in the mouth with the spit
in the mouth
that's it review done
well we know who got exercise today
right praha
yes indeed look at that tongue
wow okay so final thoughts on the z9 i
think negon has knocked it out of the
park with this honestly uh i've used the
z72 the z62 and those were very
impressive cameras i love the low iso
performance the image quality as i
mentioned in a number of my reviews for
years i i find that nikon has some of
the best color science out of any
mirrorless camera system to date and it
holds true in this but of course now
you're getting that much better auto
focusing um the build quality of the z9
is just tremendous as i showed
previously compared to the f5 i mean the
f5 in 1996
was
it was something special
for the sports camera world
and now in 2021
nikon is back with the z9
some of that dna is brought into this
camera of course with all the latest
technology the fact that we can shoot 8k
for i mean a longer period of time than
any other consumer mirrorless camera out
there on the market says something you
know
20 frames 30 frames 120 frames per
second at 11 megapixels with this camera
i mean and some of you say why can't you
do more megapixels do you need more
megapixels at that at that speed no you
don't you're basically taking a still
from video at that point in time
and 30 frames at
normal jpeg is great for sports
photographers and wildlife photographers
that are
if you're you know shooting for a job
you need to send it over to over to your
editor right away you don't need raw you
need a jpeg to send it over get
published get it out there asap on the
wire that's why jpegs are still very
important to this day and age now for us
hobbyists out there we like raw 20
frames is more than adequate as a matter
of fact you saw a lot of the images
we're shooting here today of course i
did shoot these in raw but we can't show
them because it's not in lightroom as of
yet but later on we will do a more of a
detailed review on this camera i'll show
you the raw images but i can tell you
right now
as you saw
they're spectacular
paired with a lens like the 70 to 200 f
2.8 the 51.2 and of course the 500 at
5.6
i mean we're talking some fantastic
glass paired with the z9
this is just a beast of a camera i'm a
fan and i can't wait to get this uh my
hands back on it for a full in-depth
review anyway those are my first
impressions on the z9 let me know your
thoughts in the comments section below
is this a camera you're looking to pick
up any questions i'll try to answer them
for you subscribe like always follow us
on facebook until the next one take care
[Music]
[Music]